we have some great big pieces here at
the bellagio this is jerry bowling
here's our water goddess of spring in
the conservatory she's 32 feet tall he's
the executive director of horticulture
at the bellagio
jerry takes care of las vegas secret
garden a serene oasis hidden away from
the hustle and bustle of the strip
these are my plants
and this is my show
[Music]
jerry doesn't do it alone ed libby is
the creative genius behind it all my
name is ed libby and this is the secret
garden of las vegas
five times a year ed designs a new
floral wonderland for the bellagio
conservatory and botanical gardens my
career started quite by accident i was a
driver in a flower shop while i was in
school for set design and my career kind
of snowballed after that 34 years later
as creative director ed is churning out
elaborate landscaping masterpieces i
think everything about the bellagio is
completely unique to vegas i mean it's
completely over the top this is not
something that people see in real life
as people get closer to it we call it
the up close magic and they realize that
the flowers are made out of other
flowers and the 14-foot birds are made
out of seeds and the beautiful water
goddess rising from the sea with a pearl
in her hands made out of moss and once
ed's designs are given the green light
jerry and his team get to work good
morning travis and it's a lot of work
to bring the floral fantasy to life the
gardens are closed to the public and a
team of 125 transforms the space during
one show we'll go through about 80 000
flowers and the flowers are just the
beginning there's also 40-foot props
naturally one question i always get
asked
how do we get these big props in the
conservatory in the middle of the hotel
the larger installations are brought in
pieces no larger than 10 feet by 10 feet
this is the only way the team can get
them through the door
[Music]
we also use a crane and it's more than
just heavy lifting and gardening we uh
bring in a feng shui master for chinese
new year's all in the name of beauty and
cultural accuracy i don't think that
anybody really understands what it is
until they come here it's really this
incredibly lush oasis in the middle of
the las vegas strip together ed and
jerry have created a uniquely tranquil
place that could only exist in vegas
equal parts glamour and zen
[Music]